moment moment moment informationen
sollen ein fahrzeug eintreiben soll das
bitte funktionieren
die antwort quanten thermodynamik und
stand eines tanks oder einer batterie
gibt es einen informationsspeicher und
den füllt man auch in dem man die
während der fahrt geschriebene
informationen mit hilfe von elektrischer
energie wieder löscht bot ja das video
übrigens in zusammenarbeit mit
technology review entstanden und am ende
bekommt ihr einen gratis heft der
wirklich hammer zeitschrift geschenkt
nicht um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen von der thermodynamik quasi
der klassische schwester der quanten
thermodynamik habt ihr sicher schon mal
das ein oder andere mal im
physikunterricht gehört im neunzehnten
jahrhundert waren die menschen endlich
in der lage sich durch die erfindung der
dampfmaschinen und lokomotiven schneller
fortzubewegen als mit pferdestärke die
prozesse in diesen maschinen wurden dann
von verschiedenen forscherinnen und
forschern genauer untersucht und in den
so genannten haupt setzen der
thermodynamik auch schriftlich
festgehalten energie in einem system
kann sich nur dann ändern wenn arbeit
oder wärme zu oder abgeführt werden so
der erste satz wärme kann nicht von
einem körper von niedriger temperatur
auf einen körper von höherer temperatur
übergehen so der zweite satz dazu gibt
es seit 1865 die abstrakte größe der
sogenannten entropie das maß für
unordnung es kann nur größer werden oder
aber gleich bleiben übertragen auf alle
wärmekraft maschinen wie etwa
verbrennungsmotoren bedeutet das dass
sie eben nur einen bestimmten maximalen
effizienz grad erreichen können in der
fachsprache wird dies als carnot
wirkungsgrad bezeichnet diesen ganzen
regeln und setzten zufolge ist ein
perpetuum mobile also nicht möglich
nichts kann aus mechanischer arbeit
wärme erzeugen oder aus wärme
mechanische arbeit und sich so unendlich
weiter bewegen
doch diese standard regeln der
thermodynamik gelten nicht in der
alltagswelt der moleküle und atome
zumindest sind einige forschungsdienst
davon überzeugt unter anderem tobias
schätz von der universität freiburg
zitat der quanten
hält sich nicht an die regeln der
thermodynamik und er hat ein eigenes
beispiel dazu konzipiert einen
mikroskopisch kleinen kristall er
besteht aus fünf ionen in einer
elektromagnetischen falle ein angeregtes
ion gibt seine energie als schwingung an
den kristall ab und fühlt sich somit ab
normalerweise würde sich diese
schwingung quasi totlaufen doch nicht in
solch kleinen dimensionen hier wirft das
ende des kristalls die schwingung zurück
und der sion wird wieder angeregt die
wärme kehrt hier also wieder zu ihrem
ursprung zurück und fließt nicht ab das
ganze kann man auch als nano kühlung
bezeichnen und schon 2016 hatte ein
forschungsteam aus mainz eine solche
wärme kraft maschine gebaut und zwar die
kleinste der welt sie besteht aus einem
einzelnen kalium ionen eingesperrt in
einem elektrischen wechselfeld das dazu
führt dass es sich nur in eine richtung
bewegen kann quasi wie ein kolben in
einem zylinder elektrisches rauschen
heizte das ion an laserstrahlen kühlt es
dann wieder ab das diente als antrieb
vorstellbar also ein ein auto mega
kühlschrank mit dem sich nanoelektronik
kühlen ließe falls man diesen kreis
prozess der seo motors umkehren könnte
das große ziel der theoretischen
physikerinnen und physiker den
wirkungsgrad solcher atom maschinen über
das thermodynamische limit zu erhöhen
also dass kano limit überschreiten
dazu könnte die heisenbergsche
unschärferelation dienen nach der sich
impuls und ort eines zeichens nicht
gleichzeitig ganz genau bestimmen lassen
um dies umzusetzen müsste man den ort
des atoms sehr exakt bestimmen sodass
sein impuls um bestimmt wird
dies führe wiederum zu fluktuation die
dem atom die benötigten kräfte verleihen
um das kann ohne mit zu überschreiten
doch es gibt auch kritiker den diese
idee bezweifeln beispielsweise der
vierziger renato renner von der eth
zürich
dass man auf diese weise den zweiten
hauptsatz um geben könnte ist eine
illusion
um den wirkungsgrad über das
thermodynamische erlaubte zu steigern
müsste man also immer wissen welche
auswirkung die fluktuation hat und nur
im positiven fall den motor betreiben
soll es liegt im wesen einer fluktuation
dass sie eben nicht vorhersagbar ist
seiner meinung nach
dann eben nicht nur fluktuationen die
den wirkungsgrad erhöhen sondern auch
welche die ihn senken
doch renner ist der quanten
thermodynamik nicht ganz abgeneigt und
erinnert an ein gedankenexperiment von
1871 hier sitzt einen dämon an einer
klappe zwischen zwei luft gefüllten
behältern und hat die aufgabe diese
klappe zu öffnen und zu schließen dies
führt dazu dass sich letztendlich in dem
einen behälter die schnellen moleküle
und in dem anderen die langsam befinden
sprich warm schnell langsamkeit dazu
muss keine energie aufgewendet werden
solange die klappe reibungsfrei gelagert
ist die moleküle sind also geordnet und
somit ist die entropie gesunken
verbotenerweise somit ließe sich mit der
differenz der temperatur eine wärme
kraftmaschine betreiben und zwar eine
die ewig läuft die lösung für dieses
paradoxon liegt wohl im gehirn des
dämons das hatte ein forschungsteam in
den 80er jahren herausgefunden
denn er muss alle moleküle und deren
geschwindigkeiten sehen sie auf die
klappe zu kommen um diese korrekt zu
bedienen doch auch sein gehirn ist
irgendwann voll da alle informationen
abgespeichert werden müssen heisst also
diese infos muss man löschen um das
spiel weiter zu spielen dazu renner
durch dieses löschen muss gemäss dem
zweiten hauptsatz soviel entropie
entstehen dass die gesamtbilanz größer
als null wird das ganze konnte vor einem
jahr 2017 auch in einem experiment
belegt werden ein supraleitender ring
verstärkte einen mikrowellen puls immer
weiter das entspricht dem immer wärmer
werdenden behälter das
gedankenexperiment doch die bedingung
dass dies funktionierte die
informationen über den quantenzustand
des rings in einem mikrowellen
resonators dem dämon mussten erst
gespeichert und dann auch wieder
gelöscht werden also so kann das ganze
tatsächlich funktionieren das experiment
zeigte eben dass alle hauptsätze der
thermodynamik erfüllt waren
denn für das löschen der information
brauchte es dann energie aufgewendet
werden muss das fazit also auch wenn die
idee mit dem motor als festplatte erst
einmal verrückt klingt sie könnte
vielleicht realität werden zumindest im
mikrokosmos ja vielen dank an technology
review in zusammenarbeit mit der
redaktion dieser richtigen hammer zeit
ist dieses ja ich finde mind blowing
video entstanden und exklusiver blick
zum zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein
geschenk bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe
gratis wenn ihr auf diesen link hier
oben klickt das lohnt sich richtig da
sind noch mehr coole themen drin und ich
darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken neuer revolutionärer
raumfahrt antrieb bis dann bleibt dran